the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
welcome everybody to the 2022 summer
chess classic here at the st louis chess
club i am grand master alejandro ramirez
to bring you all of the action with
grand master christian carella alejandro
always a pleasure to be here with you in
studio b casting the games of some of
the best chess players we have here in
st louis tell us a bit about these two
tournaments that we have on our hands we
have two very strong round robins going
on right now they're four grand master
some of them are between the ratings of
2500 and 2600 the other is between 2600
and 2700 not quite the level that you're
thinking of the candidates the singfield
cup but they're almost there there's
other youth players that are trying to
break into the lead they're the 2600
highs that are trying to get back to
2700 and we have a ton of very strong
players here huge opportunity for this
players to uh prove their medal but how
about the standings in group a and
before we start with the standings we do
have some breaking news yeah
unfortunately kovit did strike the
summer chess classic ray robson had to
withdraw from the event as he did test
positive just before his fourth round
started uh his results so far against
yuyani gregory opparin and abimanu
mishra will be a null half a point will
be taken away very unfortunate very
unfortunate but uh the game still count
for rating
no points are awarded for the remaining
games and christian tell us how that
leaves group a currently well
the standings in group a look as follows
tied for the first position we have
benjamin gledura jonas beer and yu yang
yin actually out of this three yu yang
yi is the only player that already
played ray robson so half a point has
been subtracted from his total score he
is the only player on plus two sam
savion and abhimanyu mishra are tied for
fourth position with two points nicolas
the other in seoul sixth position tied
for seventh position on ram jacobian
ilya smirin and grigori oparin with one
point a piece and how about the b group
alejandro in the b group we have three
people with plus one guillermo vasquez
jj alimorandi and camille dragoon they
all have two and a half points out of
four and it's uh more than half the
tournament actually following them there
in fourth position with fifty percent
joe jian chao brandon jacobs and michael
antipa christopher you and john burke
are all there meanwhile tigran christina
and nico having a bit of a tough
tournament with the armenian player on
one and a half points and the youngster
from yale with only one
and the tournament format alejandro it's
easy enough it's two round robin
tournaments of 10 players each while one
of them is down now down to nine
classical chess for you guys 90 minutes
for the first 40 moves 30 minutes from
the rest of the game and a 30 second
increment all throughout very
traditional uh chess format here and the
schedule is quite straightforward we
have been playing
one game a day starting a june 2nd now
we are monday june 6th round number five
every single round starts at 1 p.m
except the last one friday june the 10th
which is going to start two hours
earlier our show our live show starts
two and a half hours later at 3 30 p.m
central time if necessary we will have
playoffs and friday june 10th at 5 00 pm
and tell us a bit about social media
alejandro and how the audience can
engage with us of course join us on all
kinds of media we're on twitter at the
summer chess classic and you can join us
on chats both on youtube and on twitch
i'll be monitoring both for the best
questions i am already seeing the chat
is pretty active today extra morning
this is great and uh
a program that we have here at the st
louis chess club is that for every 75
dollars that we're receiving in
donations through twitch through subs
through donations uh we're gonna be able
to provide a full semester of chess
programming for one of our talented
youth here at the st louis chess club
they'll have programming some of the
best chess coaching available so you're
not only donating to the club you're not
donating to us you're donating to the
children of st louis that are trying to
improve in chess and we have so many
projects uh
in so many ways around the chess world
and this is the great thing about the st
louis just club it builds the player
from the foundation all the way to the
sink field cup and the u.s chess
championships absolutely level and tell
us a bit about the pairings for group a
what do we have alejandro well we have
four games for you remember that robson
is not playing so his opponent will be
getting a bye nicole osteodoro is
playing white against yuyanyi samsevian
is playing white against gregorio parent
and aranja kobian is playing white
against young jonas beer but the matchup
for the day in my opinion is this one
between avi manu and miesha only 13
years of age and benjamin gladuar
established grand master who goes
currently to webster university so he is
a local player he's currently on plus
one well abby manuel mishra even though
he has two points only half a point less
than benjamin he's also on plus one
remember that he's uh resulting against
ray robson is not counted so both of
these players on plus one basically
fighting for the lead of the event uh
it's just a great game absolutely just a
great game and we see abimanu mishra
let's not forget he's by far the lowest
rated player in this event if i'm not
mistaken the next one is somewhere close
to 100 points higher rated than himself
he's only 25 20 but he earned the spot
to fight against these great players by
winning the spring chess classic b group
yeah he he really had a fantastic
tournament it wasn't a smooth sailing he
actually lost i believe around two or
three against round two he started off
with half of
two yeah and then he scored six and a
half out of the remaining seven yeah
that's just uh that's just sick
incredible and right now he's just
putting a tremendous display of pure
chess fighting against these tremendous
players and actually holding his own
yeah
he started very well i mean the fact
that he's plus one in this tournament
speaks volumes absolutely he got a
little lucky let's call it lucky uh
yesterday against jonas beer
for sure this game was completely lost
but he was resourceful he didn't give up
he
uh was able to bring the game back and
actually drew what was completely a lost
position and he's currently against
benjamin ledour i'm not a huge fan of
his position let's remind our audience
that we're not nor using engines let me
turn off mine
uh we're not using engines for
this broadcast because we kind of want
to have fun that's why and which means
that not all of our evaluations are
correct actually we've
thrown out a lot of evaluations in the
program that are quite wrong but it just
gives to exemplify how tough chess is
and how grandmasters like us think about
positions and how the grandmasters that
are in the play hall are probably
perceiving the the positions not so much
the computer evaluations
absolutely and uh what we have right now
you said that you don't necessarily
enjoy his position as white i'm looking
at it and i sort of like it i understand
the knight on g2 well there's an absence
of the light square bishop close to the
king the usual fiance bishop on g2 that
no longer is on the board but at the
same time knight on b5 is holding the
bishop on d8 hostage for the moment
because right the bishop on d8 has to
defend the pawn on c7 now the knight on
g2 and what i think uh his plan is with
this last move knight from e3 that
jumped all the way to g2 well is to just
simply break with the move f4 and in the
meantime you have to find a
configuration for your own pieces as
black you would love to be able to play
the move knight to g6 unfortunately
that's not possible because queen takes
h5 is coming on the board even though
you still have rook takes f2 so we will
be going into those type of variations
in just a second
very likely actually before we get into
that let's look at the pairings for
group b as well absolutely remember
there's two tournaments group b is
currently like this guillermo vazquez is
playing against
nicolas who so far not had a great event
white against jj alimorand it's one of
those games that really determines the
event if jj wins it kind of separates
himself and the rest of the pack and
niko just goes to have a terrible event
if nico wins then the tournament is more
or less even brandon jacobson is playing
as misha antipov jose and ciao who got
extremely unlucky yesterday as well
against misha antipa
that was just a barn burner the way that
yasser likes to say jojen ciao is
playing against christopher you and
camille dragon is playing the game of
the day in our opinion against john
michael burke john michael that lost
round three came back on round four and
has a fifty percent score camille
actually won the first game i think
against joe jan chao and that is correct
and has so far drawn the rest in in
incredibly messy positions i mean these
games have been pretty messy so far and
today i don't think it's an exception
they have an incredibly messy game as
well uh between these two players kamil
drago no stranger to the b group here
has actually won this event before and
as we see actually john's coach watching
him close that is really funny
liam who is the coach at webster
university uh the university that john
is currently attending now
let's go back to mishra's game against
ledura try to understand the ins and
outs of this position but actually
before we get into that we do have the
first result of the day that is sam
savion drew his uh game against grisha
oparium let's quickly go through that
one just to show the audience what
happened uh spoiler not much
c4 knight to f6 knight to c3 and we got
into this variation which to be honest
petered out quite quickly into an equal
end game and it did seem like
potentially sam savion could nurture a
better structure unfortunately for him
he was unable to do so because
immediately rook to b8 putting a lot of
pressure on the pawn on b2 you generally
respond with the move b3 the problem is
whenever you do that i will have ideas
of bishop to a3 so you have to wait for
my dark square bishop to come off the
board bishop to d6 bishop to b3 bishop
to f4 now that you committed to this
square with the bishop no longer b3
possible no longer a way
to clear out the structure for white
knight xf4 bishop to c4 back and then we
got into this
petered out position night tweet to
exchange everything make a draw call it
a day
actually they still played for another
60 moves all the way to move 40. well we
don't announce it we don't announce it
but they actually are not allowed to uh
to draw before 40. oh really yeah even
with the repetition no well the
repetition of course they could have
repeated somehow but they're very
very very unprofessional look at this
position look at this positioning
now you repeat the moves these are
what what were they doing come on
no no not very professional that was a
little unnecessary but
uh that game has finished into a draw
and that leaves grishaw pouring on a
minus one quite a disappointing result
for the young lad from mizzou after five
rounds minus one sam sevion i think he's
on fifty percent he hasn't
on the ice he hasn't lost he hasn't won
he's an all draw so far it's a little
actually a disappointing result for him
because he is such a high rated player
he has broken the 2700 barrier and
because he has 2 700 he's actually
losing six rating points yeah uh because
he's drawn every game so far i mean it
really hurt him to draw mishra i think
he lost one and a half two points just
on that game alone so it stopped staying
up near the 2700 level no absolutely so
let's go back to that game because uh
glendora did indeed come up with this
breakthrough before
white committed to the move f4 with d5 a
counter break almost that that's a
fascinating move because
there's like immediate questions that
arise at least in my mind right
yeah that's the first thing right you
take on d5 what are you taking with i
assume you take that with the pawn the
pawn queen takes e5 and
there is a chance we're blundering
something like rook e6 but
rookie six still queen to d4 and c6
takes d5
nothing right no i think that's
there's no tricks there
yeah i don't like guarantee it but i
don't see it either right but of course
you can just simply take on f2 yeah you
could take on f2 i wasn't sure that this
was gledura's intention simply because
of knight f4 in this position f4 yeah
and i didn't
so you take take take and now maybe
knight to g6 the issue with knight g6 i
had a queen h5 d5 also works yeah queen
two h five queen h5 but i think windy
five is just as good yeah queen to d5 oh
at the end you have a c6
that's not possible that's not possible
right right right take a take missing
some sort of uh tactic because of c6
attacks both knights so you do have to
focus on the pawn on h5 right queen
takes h5 and takes uh instead of queen
to d5 take take take take
and now the problem is that when you
take on h4 there's still one pawn
hanging and even if it wasn't hanging i
mean black's not playing for an
advantage no absolutely not right now
he's just much worse he's just much
worse yeah so this is not the idea
all right so let's think
back to the beginning of the sequence
after the move d5 take take take on e5
let's put our grand master hats on
alejandro are you ready no
not really
maybe you start with c6 but c6 knight
and d6 is a bit worried and i do
understand that this knight is starting
to look a bit fishy yeah especially
after queen g6 but then i take i
continued taking right you're a greedy
boy christian that's the only thing i
can do right now
they're not my pieces yeah let's go
bishop b6 really yeah why not they're
not my pieces
i guess that's your only explanation
rook f2
and you want to take with the rook yes i
think so because d4 queen g3 i think is
one mistake i think with the rook again
why am i playing so fast
wait wait just one second just one
second rook takes f2 you said queen take
g3 you thought it's winning well what if
i just think takes queen
here check uh it's not winning check
it might just be a draw though
do i have any good ways to defend this i
don't see it probably not i have queen
g5 but you actually have to protect the
rock and you lose
looks like a draw right so i guess just
a draw
well we went a little fast on it it
looked scary for white but we did it
it's the kind of variations that you
think a grand master is looking at like
what what do you look after d5 it's this
forcing variations take stick sticks
king's being very weak in this position
not only blacks not only whites right
yeah see there's a lot of pressure on
white's king
in the position that we have currently
but if you kind of use your mind as as a
grand master you realize that black's
king is actually a source of counter
play as well so the more lines you open
especially with the queen in the center
the more you're starting to start to
have resources absolutely absolutely
yeah rook to f2 is uh one move c6 is
another move that he needs to consider
in this position and calculate very
complicated um
it's a very complex position very very
complex and of course by the way after
c6 you don't have yeah you also can go
into the lines then with knight to d6
you can drop back knight to d4 and just
play the position as it is
this bishop would love to go to c7 right
and then put a lot of pressure on g3
unfortunately you cannot go there and
once again you have the same problem
where is this knight going knight to g6
you would love to get it there
unfortunately queen takes h5 is coming
on the board and as you nicely pointed
out once you do play this move rook to
f2 i have a way to cut off
your position more or less with knight
to f4 of course i'm still gonna need one
more tempe to uh get this rook protected
but potentially knight to e6 is a big
threat yeah i'm i'm very curious about
this move d5 uh i don't quite
huge decision but yeah let's see how
he only thought for six minutes it's a
very unforced decision right you don't
have to go d5 by any stretch of the
imagination actually most logical moves
were good for black he must feel that in
these variations he's somehow getting
the upper hand i just don't
i don't see it yet
i think we should just let them think
because
we
we have a lot of games to look at yeah
we it's just such a complex position
that we would get lost in the variations
i think one game that i think it's
most likely uh over
very soon is this battle between
jacobian
and the young dane bier what happened to
this king i i think the king is just
getting check made it very soon
hard to believe you survived this is not
surviving no not with the bishops i
think this is completely over this might
be very close to resignation yeah um
because going to g2 is a move bishop
takes c5
i can probably take on h6 but i really
don't want to i want to keep the tension
as it is
this one is just looking completely
busted
for the young day
25 minutes by the way for around kobe
and only 14 minutes left
for
jonas beer
what what do you think about
distribution i think that gh
is actually just winning
right and i believe this is what he's
calculating right yeah it's an ugly move
but so what if you take
probably just f5
oh f5 that's so that's nice
and then i put the queen on somewhere i
don't know no but why wouldn't you do
this alejandra
i think at this point we're just picking
we're picking ways to win right so i
mean gh must be made you put a queen i
mean this king has no defense there are
like so many ways of winning this
position if you do play this move king
takes h5 queen to g2 queen to g4 is
coming knight f6 is coming you can
resign uh great commentary you you would
like to go back the problem is that
knight f6 is coming
and then now f5 is coming on the board
and this is just i mean boom it's just
over i think i think gh just wins i'm
sure there's other moves that win
it's an ugly move and this is why he's
spending so much not necessarily so much
time but this is why he's still thinking
yeah he's very confident i mean there's
no way aram lets this one go this is
just
totally over all right let's let's not
make it as easy for it no it but it is
for white let's just go king to h8 let's
try to put up some resistance i'll go
queen g2 anyway going to g2 all right do
you threaten anything
you're not really concerned okay knight
to f6
it's a good point
so let's defend
that doesn't defend
that actually does not defend
it's quite a funny move because now if
you take with a rook
release the defense of the g7 square if
you take with the queen release the
defense of the g8 square yeah
problematic and knight f6 is not just a
pretty move i actually have a big threat
queen to g7 yep or queen j whatever you
feel like no but this is this is just
over visual yeah it is very nice i have
to admit no i i think the game is just
over right i mean i wouldn't be
surprised to turn on the engine and the
engine says it's made in something
well what does it say plus nine yeah i
mean come on this is going to plus 10
yes it's dead all right this is game
over
um
let's move on to your students game
nico tioda against you young yi we're
going to be staying with group a for the
moment queen to f5 is the last move
played
by the chinese player 27 minutes by the
way
against 12 minutes by nico theodore now
nico is generally a very fast player but
in this tournament he seems to be
spending
his time quite a lot yeah it's his first
experience with such a strong event tell
us about that well nicolas de dora is a
very talented player he doesn't come
from a traditionally very strong chess
country
he comes from greece which is a country
that has always had a decent team but
they don't have a lot of resources they
don't have a lot of support the way that
you know the russian chess federation uh
to some extent us here at the st louis
chess club have uh
abilities to play strong players they
don't have the culture they don't have
yeah it's not really part of their
of their their chess culture is very
limited let's put it that way so they've
obviously grown and they've obviously
done a lot better to the point where
right now they have a ton of talent
i mean the greek team is very strong the
greek women's team is getting stronger
and stronger every day and it's clear
that things are progressing uh in greece
and nico is a student that came to saint
louis university
barely 2500 and has made tons of
progress he actually reached 25.80
became a grand master he was only an
international master when he joined
and this is his first real test against
players of this caliber this is actually
only the second 2700 that he plays in
his entire life oh wow so
uh
this player being yoon yang yi so and
he's going to get his third very soon
he's going to have you he's going to be
playing savion very soon for his third
so certainly a competitive tournament
for him uh some uh
a chance for him to sharpen his closet a
chance for him to really measure himself
against the elite of the elite because
when you talk about a player like you
young yi
i mean this guy's just been around for a
while he's been he's been around for a
while you know what's funny i actually
looked him up before the round because i
was thinking like he must be like our
age or 30 or something the guy's 27.
he's a bit younger i know i played him
in argentine actually in 2009 at an
under 20 um world junior championship
and he was only around 25 something yeah
we drew the game and then he started
beating absolutely everybody he beat it
to rizzaga i think he drew against mvl
he finished up uh close to the top and
the guy was like only 25 20. my rating
at that time and i was just so impressed
with the ability it's the same with
dingley ren he came out of nowhere
come out of nowhere they blast through
25 26 2700 and some of them plato around
27 30 and then you get dingly rants of
the world that go all the way to 2800
but still so impressive the way they uh
make progress these chinese players yeah
and uh yay in particular has actually
reached a rating of 27.65 oh yeah yeah
so he he is a leader of the elite he's
beating carlsen he's been in tons of top
players oh yeah uh currently although uh
objectively i think his position is
pretty dubious uh this bottom d5 is
actually blocking most of his pieces and
feodoro has a really nice grip against
this uh isolated position of the pawn on
d5
it's advantage white but it's not that
clear no no no
it's
definitely an advantage definitely a
pool and definitely a chance for a young
to put some pressure on his more
experienced player uh we'll leave it at
that for at the moment let's move on to
group b alejandro we're going to start
with uh the game of the round
camel dragon versus john burton let's do
it yeah
let's see what do we have here i see uh
two bishops for uh john an exchange down
so something must have happened in this
one we do have some sort of an imbalance
in this position we have a couple of
weapons for the black side that is the
pawn on e3 the majority on the queen
side uh the two bishops of course that i
just mentioned
in return of course white has the x-ray
exchange as well as the potential
majority on the king side quite an
intriguing position but generally
whenever i see this my first instinct is
that
the site that has the material advantage
should probably be better
yeah what do we think about this that's
usually my first instinct as well on
this one in particular though
i actually like black i think
because of what everything that you said
i think it actually kind of compensates
it out and i wouldn't be surprised that
this particular position is kind of a
stylistic position in which right some
people will like the bishop some people
will like the exchange and you're not
objectively wrong for liking one or the
other of course sometimes the material
is just overwhelming sometimes the
bishops are too much compensation but in
this one i think they just about balance
each other out
and i i personally think that i would
take the black pieces
but sure
i think it's just a uh a matter of taste
and to be uh frank with you it does seem
like dragoon doesn't feel as comfortable
in the position because he's pending
he's burning through a lot of his time
right now down to his last 10 minutes
against 19 minutes and we see a move
what do we have b3 try to stop the
aggression of black spawns on the queen
side c4 was kind of a threat actually uh
i think it was a very strong strategical
threat yes maybe not immediately because
you still have to break through worry
about b3 but the moment you start
protecting the c3 square then yeah c4
becomes very strong b3 makes sense in
general okay so this is what i'm looking
at yeah maybe bishop to g4 no but bishop
to g4
you can just play a little bit right
yeah yeah yeah
yeah that you you still have this move
uh king to f1 if you would be forced to
go rook to u1 then that's a problem
because i attack from both sides um but
he played a move b3
i like b3 this is a threat right right
now rook to c1 try to put some pressure
on c5
yeah black black has to play with
certain
aggression i think yeah yeah because if
you don't if you allow rook c1 knight c3
knight d5 this king getting to e1 maybe
or something that blocks the pawn
yeah especially h3 king e2 right yeah
you get there then if you get there then
black is just worse or maybe lost so you
you need to
play with some
some potency here with the black side
absolutely uh so let's try to find the
potential yeah where's the potency right
where's the energy coming all right so i
see
this idea i would really like to plant
a bishop on d2 now can i do that
that's the problem whenever i go bishop
to a5 you immediately attack it the pawn
on c5 with rook to c1
that's uh
that's the way you create counter play
and the only
probably it's not the only way but
the one way that i see for a black try
to defend against that is to go bishop
to g4 and
you're already it feels like you're
hanging by a threat yeah yeah this
doesn't feel correct i go to c8 and i
understand that you have some ideas of
c4 bishop to d2
it's it's a one-tempo type position wow
chad's actually been very active uh
chad's suggesting bishop a5 a rook c1
bishop b4 is actually not a bad idea at
all um
because this bishop this bishop is
actually really good okay okay yes
this bishop's actually really good on b4
by the way bishop to g4 was played this
force is king f1 yes it might not be a
bad tempo for black
uh another maybe explanation for this
move is that rook c8 becomes available
that's what he wants yeah i think rook
said yeah the the rook doesn't have
a job right now
and it feels like the bishop on c7 wants
to go to d2 more than he wants to go to
before not that i think not that i think
that the position on before
is wrong but i feel that because the
rook doesn't have a job give this rap
this job to the rook
put the bishop on d2
and then follow up because it is very
uncomfortable for this request
almost a threat it's almost because
bishop i5 is following it up now at the
same time what white would love in this
position is a sequence um such as the
follow
h3 actually it's a strange move to make
i i actually don't see a good move to
make to uh
to make my point phil's chest whip says
this feels like he's going to play for
d6 look i found it
imagine the rook was on d1 and you
didn't have d1
you would love to be able to take on d2
sure
excuse me
and the position right now
transition
into a position in which i feel like
white just has the better structure
what do you think alejandro you do have
a better structure but this h-pawn is
just not going anywhere
and i will establish a pass bond with
the bishop on d3 i don't know i still
feel that it's close to equal somehow
this would be my
my initial assessment bishop to a5 was
played we might be going straight into
this line that we're thinking about
they're actually very logical moves by
the way uh we're being told that adam
hakobian has actually won his game we
uh
we felt that he was just winning in that
position you have a absolute crushing
game against jonas beer so we'll have
him from an interview just in a second
as soon as he enters the studio
absolutely
as soon as he enters the studio so
well what else do we have well let's
look at um the game between
my student
misha antipov and brandon jacobson and i
have to say
something went wrong for my student
this one is looking horrendous we just
see queen to d2 now the problem is
you're facing two bishops
you're facing these beautiful central
pawns
for white
and it doesn't feel like black has
enough compensation
i have to say i am really concerned
about the position of my student in this
one with the black pieces misha and
tipoff
but
while we uh
try to understand that position we do
have one victor of today's round the
first victor of today's round aram
hakobian aram welcome to the show
congratulations a big victory for you
you broke the ice how does that feel it
feels great obviously um i think i
played a decent game so
with against a great opponent so
tell us a bit about uh your opponent
pierre
did you have a lot of information about
him do you know him personally well i
know he's very talented uh player with
uh good openings
um so i didn't prepare for today's game
i was just watching picky blunders
that's that was my preparation that is a
good show
now take us through the game
so
the opening this is something what uh
aronian plays a lot with white so i was
kind of inspired and
i didn't know what was going on after g5
already but i thought that f4 is logical
so i played it and g4
yes
and uh e4 also logical i guess i just
have to take the center
and not to allow him d5 by the way the
engine right now is saying that black
somehow is better did you feel that way
at all
well i thought white is supposed to be
better but with d5 apparently not with
f5 the same idea i tried to find the
right breakthrough but actually with d5
did you consider this move well i
i felt that it can be strong but i was
not calculating it but
probably if i was black i would have
considered it yeah
d5 and i would assume that he wants to
meet yeah
yeah probably i was just kind of trying
to just play chess and uh complicated
yeah to have some some playable position
yeah i like it yeah and he played this
move f5 knight g2 this was logical
though of course logical yeah yeah yeah
very typical
um
castle
nice decision by europe to be i think
rook b8 i'm not sure but i was worried
about bishop d7
instead of ruby yes
just not to let ef knight f5 bishop c6
yeah
because after that i'm not sure if i'm
better but it was um
so this is easier for me
yeah
and explain to us why did you feel like
it's much easier for you right now well
yeah so after 94
the thing is that i want to take on g7
and go d4 so let's see
immediately itself
and then d4 yes and c8 bishop is stuck
always that's the key in this position
and all the time whenever he moves to
knight from f5 i have a rear gauge for
ideas what happened pretty much in the
game yeah i think he didn't play i mean
he obviously didn't play the best way he
kind of collapsed very easily
because
knight d4 takes i'm not sure if he
missed c5 but
i mean to me it was only move c5 yeah
don't allow him to play c5 himself open
up his bishop activate his pieces and
pretty much block all your offensive
yeah
take bishop to a3 yeah don't take on c5
now
wow that's quite a nice uh i was
thinking that maybe king b1 is the
better move but
yeah i don't know just to play rook c1
and you know control everything
but wishpantry also turned out to be a
good one yeah you probably have a lot of
options already yeah probably yeah so i
was
okay f5 so here i thought probably he
was considering e5
and rook g4
rook h5 and probably he missed the rook
g7
king g7 and g4
yeah and the if rook h4 well he
obviously you cannot take on g4 because
of rook g1 and i go f5 i think
yeah so here rook g1 and yeah and after
rook h4 f5 it takes for gage one
and you don't really you don't really
have to calculate this to understand
that it's lost you have to play yeah
when you have to play a move such as a
queen you can feel it yeah to avoid
checkmate this is over yeah very nice
so he played rook to b5
yes
which just allows you to break through
rock takes g7 yeah i had many options so
probably there but yeah we were having a
lot of fun with this position
me too me too i bet i bet you are rook
to b5
yeah um it was a nice finish actually
this is the same position that we
finished that oh and we said that queen
to g7 is coming you're going to play
queen g7 absolutely not quick absolutely
of course
i'm kind of upset that he didn't allow
you to play queen jesus yeah me too
he still allowed me knight f6 which is
nice yeah yeah uh beautiful game a
brilliant game i have to say um who do
you have tomorrow
as far as i know it's uh my teammate
benjamin glidura
that's going to be a big matchup i guess
you guys are having a lot of sparring
sessions we do we do in the back all
right excellent thank you very much for
joining the show and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you
and uh
yeah what a beautiful game
by young aram hacobian just devastating
attack against the young dane jonas bier
beautiful game and speaking of glendura
let's see the game of the round
in our opinion our estimation in group a
eight game between mishra and glendura
how is this one playing out right now
and alejandro welcome back well thank
you christian i'm sure you missed me uh
this well let's take a look i was
actually looking catching up with the
other games so i didn't take a look at
this one
so he ended up taking on d5 but not
taking he did take on e5
knight c6 and it feels like it was just
a straight up sack
fascinating creativity here by young
blind jamming ledura this nlg4 certainly
gives him compensation but is it is it
enough
a nice tip
can i step in a nice tip for white i
like it a four knight to g4
i get it
you more or less provoked with the last
few moves this move f4 right because you
cannot as white allow the knight to jump
to f3 so you have to defend that with
the move f4 now as a consequence this
move f4 opens up of course the a7 g1
diagonal and most likely we will be
seeing later on in the game the idea of
c6 followed by bishop to b6 but the
question is
does black have enough compensation
uh it depends on what we're talking
about also right because i think that if
we're talking about equality yes for i
mean i don't think really yeah i don't
think there's any doubt in my mind that
he has enough for equality i'm not
convinced what if i go knight d4
this nice job on
the queen side is over i want to
redirect it to e5 or g5
i think a lot will depend on whether it
gets there or not right yeah the
specifics of the position
and this is why i want to play i think i
think c6 yeah i think c6 and the knight
f3 bishop ah but they should be
successful
i completely forgot about this move yeah
yeah this might change the character of
the game yeah because once i get the mag
yeah this is over almost right yeah no
no i cannot allow this
um
no i actually forgot that and he played
it
94 right he played 94. so maybe on
yeah but you can always contest the file
i want to play c6 knight f3 rook f e6
but
trying to get for q2
because rookie 2 might be an issue now
but no but you have rookie one yeah this
is the problem that i wasn't able to
solve
that if you just contest the uh
does the open file what what does black
have in this position i don't see it i
don't see it either actually the more
the more i look at this position the
more i'm wondering
and imagine this
i play the move d4 i'm going to follow
it up with knight to e5 look you say
after d4 i can also redirect my knight
to e4 sure i think
once i get the knight to e5 knight d4
i'm gonna take that knight yeah yeah
yeah no no no i agree with you
i i don't like it no i think that
benjamin must have an idea to play c6
knight f3 d4
i think it's he missed it though no no
that he's going to go c6 knight f3 and
himself he's going to go d4 oh
d4
spicy i think but i think he has to
spicy i don't think he has a choice at
this moment it might be a good move
anyway
you get i get it it's good but how good
that's the question right we go bishop
b6 now maybe queen b3 i don't know queen
b3 is an interesting idea in many of
these positions let's get this rook
somewhere probably to e4
well that's the thing i'm controlling so
many squares right now yeah on the e
file yeah i might as well place my on
either e4 or e5
you have to stop me from going to e4 but
the problem is rook to e6 doesn't work
no i don't want to but that might
actually work
it might work but i don't know if i want
to play it the thing is i wanted my
queen going to be three in many cases
the thing is i don't see that choice i
think we might have to go into this
variation because i don't know what else
black plays okay
oh
c5
geez never mind why are we like this
question
it's the same idea but with the button
c5 so i can take on d4 it makes a lot
more sense
oh my goodness
not even good morning saying look no
it's not like it's like 3 p.m here what
on earth man almost good evening st
louise but we're still not awake yeah
yeah knight to f3 d4 yes yeah i mean
this is the idea otherwise why are you
playing this position yeah oh this makes
so much more money makes much more sense
here and now here we can see that black
probably does have some compensation
because knight e3 will be an idea in so
many positions knight g5 can be met with
queen b3 but as you're mentioning with
your arrows black also has to be worried
about the ideas that white has knight g5
e4 we're just coming to a1 and let's not
forget it's a pawn nevertheless
this is a game yeah this is a problem
when white gets the pawn to d4 is not
just not a game yeah that's game over
yeah but after c5 knight f3 d4 this is
definitely a game
cool well we're going to leave it at
that and we're going to let this players
under their next options uh 11 minutes
and 58 seconds for benjamin gledura and
only eight minutes and 30 seconds and
counting for misra yeah for 10 moves
which is actually quite a lot uh
considering the position that if we
played quickly
i expect d4 nope
what queen to d7 what
can i just immediately
you allow me to play d4 i'm going to
play before i mean i don't
i know there's a pawn hanging on a4 but
i'm not yeah
what is this what is this move queen d7
is such a random move
it does not feel correct d4 for me in my
estimation was almost an automatic right
in mind too i i thought the whole point
of going c5 was to go so strange okay so
d4 you take this pawn right
you want to take this i don't know man i
i don't want to take it but i'm assuming
that he because he played queen d7 he
wants to take it i don't want to take it
i don't i don't look at that point and
be like oh what a yummy pawn on a for
perhaps you want to take on d4 first
maybe
not to allow me to take on c5 yeah yeah
and then i take it maybe here i take and
okay black's fine probably but i
wouldn't have considered going into this
and giving you e5
how fine is black i'm not sure actually
sn95 is very annoying it's it's a
serious knife
yeah the the main problem is that
there's no there's no good move to
prevent it out here and i know you know
actually
yeah i understand there's some tactics
but they don't work there's no pins
that i can see work immediately
because the knight on g4 can only take
e3 or e5 right it cannot take both
knights so what if i
take here can i take with the f pawn
take back with the queen
oh
what a tricky guy i got you got him
and you cannot take me with this king
because queen d1 and if you take with
the rook bishop d4 that's beautiful that
is beautiful christian this must be the
reason benjamin gladuar went for this
line
that's a good point that's a good point
alejandro yeah
he did not see half of this
he did not see half of this because i
think we're just throwing moves
at our audience and our audience
definitely hopefully enjoys it hopefully
shout us out on youtube or twitch i am
following the chat
thanks for everybody that's following
how many posts can black sacrifice a lot
trust me yeah yeah all right queen to d7
look at least queen to d7
is a move that confuses oh i confused
mishra oh
look at that
b3 that that is respect that is respect
for your opponent knowing that your
opponent is a strong player you see that
move queen d7 it's like this guy figured
something out i'm gonna defend my phone
but it just makes d4 stronger he has to
follow it up with d4 it just makes d4 so
much stronger
instantaneous response has to come
not only that you play the move d4 and
you get this beautiful pawn on d4 and
potential outposts for knight on e3
you're also opening up
the square for the queen now for the
queen yeah so let's actually try to
analyze this a little bit because d4
what do i play here
i don't want to go c4 but
on the other hand i do want to go c4 you
know like i don't conceptually want to
play c4 and leave d4
but i want to close your bishop i don't
want to re i don't know i don't want to
leave d4 i unders
you know in a position where it's
defended i understand
but at the same time you don't want to
give me the b4 or the b force yeah
exactly i don't want your bishop to be
uh
because if i get my bishop to be for
controlling the exactly
that's a problem so
i see this move d4 b c4
remember it's still a pawn
i could go knight e3 this is the main
thing right all right so let's uh let's
spice it up take
maybe i take with the pawn
queen into forced otherwise e2 is coming
with oh but queen how are you defending
his queen h3
who defends who defends the spawn
reminds me of uh the move that grigorio
party missed in his game against yu yang
yi queen to h4 h4 right right right it's
penetration and somehow you cannot
defend the g3 square same idea when h4
attacking g3 couldn't defend the square
you can you can behind it but
unfortunately that allows e2 so we're
going to exchange e2 and we can sign the
score sheets
we're expecting d4 and this one i have
to say we uh chose it as the game of
dane definitely yes well outside of the
devastation the jacobian put on beer
yeah that was just incredible i mean
yeah that's great actually um this one
is quite a good game as well no i i
think the webster guys are really
bringing in today both hakobian and
benjamin gladua both of them as you
mentioned students at webster university
they're doing great they're good they're
very aggressive today abhimaan and misha
definitely putting better resistance
than beer
what's going on in this game i'm not
sure but it is a fight and it's a fun
fight yep absolutely there's only one
game left in the
in group a's which is one move out of
time control so let's just take a quick
glance at it
absolutely nicolas is your door against
you young ye
and it's obviously why it's better the
only question is how much better
let me say this is a little bit of
commentator bias but if your knee was
white i'd say that white is just winning
that's true right
but he's black that's true because i see
your k3 we have a rating bias a total
rating bias and that totally exists in
commentary don't let anybody fool you
and tell you it doesn't exist of course
it exists yeah yeah yeah so
but i i just don't see a defense i mean
rook a3 is coming and that's right it's
a big problem and rook c5 is going to be
met by knight b3 even not immediately
i'll i'll temple my way in all right
let's see let's try to do this 0k3
rook c5
i hear a weasel a little bit i'm not
going to go knight b3 immediately
because i assume rook c2 even though
that was my point yeah yeah even though
i'm not completely sure about this
enemies but i'm going to play bishop d3
first sure
not an id3 is a serious threat yep
yeah knight b3 and i don't have the
penetration yeah the second rank that's
a problem
so how do i defend
or
better yet how do i find some sort of
counterplay yeah let's go knight to c4
oh knight c4 is a move the thing is it's
a move
look i don't like the position yeah i'm
not happy with my position it's the only
thing i can do at this point well the
thing is rook c3 and uh somebody else no
no no no no oh next xp don't do that
alejandro no i follow him for so many
tricks today what's wrong with me don't
do that
oh and i get i actually lose yeah maybe
maybe you can save it somehow yeah maybe
even
but right you don't want this of course
so rook to d3 big moment right now i
mean
really needs to uh pull a rabbit out of
his head to save this one because this
is such a difficult end game yeah it's
not the first time that he's under
pressure he actually was also severely
under pressure against benjamin gladua
in the first game i think he was under
pressure the entire game from the
opening with the white people with the
white pieces but he survived that one um
certainly a fighter we'll see if he can
save this one we do feel this position
is pretty bad
yeah no your your student is doing a
tremendous job piling up the pressure
right now on you young let's move on to
the b group and see what's happening in
there because
we did check a couple of games but we
left a lot of them untouched and we're
going to jump to this game between
vasquez and haru tunian
four minutes this is the first thing i'm
seeing four minutes for harold union and
actually quite a difficult position
yeah i mean f5 is
hanging in like every position right
yeah i'm gonna pick that guy up as soon
as possible
and the problem is once i do that your
position almost collapses
it's true because uh there's a lot of
pressure on the air file
how did you call this the
algae
gun yeah the king is gone alakine is
gone technically it's with the queen
on the first round queen on f1 f1
technically yeah yeah alekhine's gone i
like it yeah i did not know that though
yeah yeah it's a old chass uh all chest
chest i haven't actually heard of allah
since i was a kid those are like kids
books they're like oh i like honestly
yeah yeah no it looks good for uh for
white definitely vasquez with
some serious pressure against harold
union now what's happening in the game
between cheka and ali marandi that's an
important one for the standings right as
i was mentioning the gate what's on
earth uh
things could really go one of two
different ways but
it seems like black is just up in
exchange
he is
and how do we make this move knight ah
it's black actually yeah
to move i think it'd be a very
interesting position if it was white to
move but first of all
why is knight e6 not completely
immediately
because christian kerala so if you take
the point being that i take you cannot
take back because that's just a
checkmate and if you don't take back
that's also a checkmate
i guess you have to go queen
e for
now
ah okay okay okay
so now if you take take and you
establish this pin right
and if you take on g2 i just take back
because i've sufficiently defended
that answers uh our question why 96 is
not immediately winning
but it might not be let's continue yeah
you can even play
i know d5 you have queen e5
mmm
it becomes kind of annoying actually
always establishing this pin but at the
same time yeah think continue right
queen b2 maybe knight ef5
oh it's made of g2
yeah you can never leave playing or post
playing great shots today christian
you can play the move rook to d1
yeah but it's not yet over it's not over
but i do feel that we're just kind of
trying to survive the next few months
with white but you are down in exchange
it's not the cleanest at the same time i
regret it it's not the cleanest exchange
there's a serious there's a serious
problem
but it is an exchange
definitely is an exchange and it does
feel like
probably he just needs to put the
finishing technical touches yeah this
would be my first impression that black
is very close to winning and he just
needs to figure out a couple of good
moves perhaps
important good moves but good moves
queen d2 is a very logical move uh
because if one of the knights going to
f5 doesn't work then you just you're
just lose this one doesn't
actually
queen takes h3 what how do you win uh
you got this way and this one does one i
think so because the best you can get is
this
but this is
that's just very lost
so maybe not and if you don't then the
point being with the queen on h3 you
defend h2 like this you don't you don't
so
queen d2 you have to play the other
knight uh to f5 i think
and maybe maybe still alive right i mean
knight g7 is interestingly not a threat
because we need to check
but
what what is black's move right
it's kind of a weird position actually
what if i do this once again i'm
actually very curious if h5 is also a
good move h5 it's a second move but it
might be good
so this this and i was hoping knight h3
was like more than a check right that
was my hope i didn't see why i was more
than a czech how do i put a queen where
do you put the queen yeah
that's funny because queen g4 knight h3
right and queen d1
finally the explanation of why
all of this works yeah 92 not f2 what
oh yeah yeah yeah wait it's not that
easy it's not that easy yet
oh i don't what a what a mess
yeah you're right it's not that easy
should be easy but
but after the game from yesterday on
people versus
this type of like uh
pie yeah yeah yeah
i never know how to assess them anymore
i'm like i
it completely changed the paradigm
for uh for for me christian we have a
very serious question in the chat yes
who is the better dancer you are me
oh you by
my landslide i don't think so i don't
think that's true i i don't dance i mean
men don't dance that's true men don't
die nonetheless
glad we clarified that
praiser is warning us that he has a
video cue up
that is uh he doesn't have it it doesn't
exist
yeah you can google no no no this is
ungoogleable yes that is still there
it's still on youtube i'm gonna get can
you take that down
do some research guys you will find uh
some interesting videos on the st
lucious clubs we've got a youtube
channel no all right
leaving it at that let's uh go to zuzon
ciao versus christopher you
so white strategically got everything he
wanted the pattern h6
because the palm was not on h6 when we
left that right
whatever happened here
yeah the pawns on h6 he's got a passport
on e5
and he's pressuring this weakness on b6
the other thing is that black does have
some counter play with the rook and
maybe the queen
but it looks it looks pretty negligible
i think
why it's like a few moves away from
winning
is it i think so i i i just have trouble
believing that passive defense can hold
this position
okay how do you break well we'll make a
move first right
king of seven chaos and i can start
thinking of
g4 but of course i don't want to play g4
right away with the rook on
coming to c2 so maybe i'll play rook b2
now that you let me i'm going to go to
this device i just don't know where
you're going i'm just hiding my king on
the other side and then i'm going to
stay like that
i'm saying that you
i don't see your parade basically yeah
you know what actually i do have a plan
so once i get the king to d7 i go rook
c7 kicks here it can be seven and this
is not as bad yeah no maybe yeah once i
get the king on the other side i'm happy
i actually like this king march a lot
kf7 this particular move looks very
logical because
we have to ask the question yeah what
happens after g4
i mean the king is very safe on g3 maybe
there's no reason to be afraid of it
exactly yeah
this looks really bad
yeah if you take on f5 i'm not very
happy
with my position if you open up the g
file yeah
something feels wrong about my position
can you have seven play we didn't think
it was a logical move huh king to f7
yeah
okay it's not the end of the world and
maybe black can try to get some kind of
play i think i'll just go check her king
aid the way you played it really yeah
does even even at the end i didn't see
the immediate threat
that's fine
i'm actually just kind of reactive at
this point i just defended against queen
g6 because that was a threat how about
making on i guess c6 i don't know if i
can do better how do we get there
okay king d7 you don't care but what if
i take the pawn yeah this is the
questions that we have to start asking
because i go king c6 you take on h7 i go
f4 and then we start wondering if this
is a perpetual if it's not a perpetual
get some sort of a mass song if if
black's actually winning
no wait
i mean maybe right yeah it kicks pretty
weak
there's a brave move christian carla
why not i mean i don't see your checks i
see one but then i continue attacking
that's the thing
you might be getting checkmated also
yeah because rxe1 is a very strong
threat
it's almost a checkmate
yeah
so you might actually continue yeah i go
to f7 and it continues like the game
just goes on at the end oh you didn't
give up no no no of course why would i
give up i think my thing black's better
oh wow
why would i why would i give up
a king what a guy
yeah for good reason yeah right this is
actually not that easy it's just a mess
and both sides they're kind of getting
materials like you still have any checks
you don't you still don't have any
checks what's your threat i don't have
anything that's such a funny thing i
mean i could take on h6 you could give
me a petrol right but if you do that
then i go here and then i exchange the
rooks and i have a feeling i will be
winning this one you think this is
winning um i'm close to it i mean yeah i
mean one tourist whole game right right
right right right right if i managed to
get the king somewhere around here then
obviously yeah okay we went a little too
crazy and this is perhaps the reason we
see queen f3 just f3 by the way movie
as a grand master and since we're
analyzing this position of course we
want to see g4 g4 is a terrible move
because practically speaking you should
never play the movie g4 before move 40.
oh okay
but at the same time i get it if the
king goes on the other side g4
disappears i i understand but not an
option anymore it's such a it's such a
committal move
okay but no no no
he didn't play g4 but he did create
another threat and another way to stop
the king from getting to d7 and that is
queen f3 king is 7-0 to b5 is coming
yeah rugby 5 is very annoying uh you
don't want to give up the c file with
the move rook d8 we don't have a good
way of defending d5 and d5 is actually
an integral part of black's position by
the way he played the move king to e7 i
think rb5 will be seen very perhaps we
can actually see the players they have
the players right now we don't have a
shot of these particular players
unfortunately today we are very limited
on our cameras
perfect let's go at the game with
cameras
tell me a game with cameras alejandro or
i don't know man
i don't have a piece of paper with the
camera it seems like everything else but
this game has a camera so
um
that's how this broadcast works
everything else but this one all right
let's go
actually uh vazquez we've already seen
we uh
check out we've already seen
jacobson oh my goodness that's an extra
piece
it's three pounds but
they're isolated points three points
which is going to be two two
and then we're going to play three
versus two forever right which you win
eventually but
it's not that easy it's not that easy
also this pawn is the wrong color in
case we exchanged uh
the rooks
yeah you you guys would be surprised how
difficult it is to win three
um
positions you get this and do you get it
as easily so let's go look to c4 you
pick this guy up yeah and i'll get now i
go to or king i mean i'll i'll pick up
this very easily
king e2 can use three bishop d5 for
example you'll find a way to pick it up
i'll pick i'll find a way to pick it up
the only question is i actually don't
think fox a good move
really i think you should keep the point
in
half seven i think this is objectively
lost anyway no matter what you do is
subjectively lost i analyze this at some
point a long time ago what a waste of
time
that's the thing yeah you answer the
problem and then you forget it the
promise i also analyzed this yeah you
know what else i analyzed that was kind
of silly
knight and rook
this exact end game but with a nine
instead of instead of a bishop sure and
it's actually extremely hard
you would expect it to be easier easy
it's not you have to zook along the rook
it sounds it sounds crazy that's my
favorite camera there we go it's like
we're peeking in
it looks like we're zooming in from like
a curtain or something
we're behind a wall we're being told oh
that's even like we're hiding
like this creepers he doesn't see us he
doesn't see the camera he doesn't see us
he doesn't hear us this is very
disturbing
all right
we'll leave it at that alejandro
uh let's go to this game between
camille dragoon and john burke yeah we
by the way we would do things yeah
and we think it's lost
that one is going to last forever this
one's going to last way after the
broadcast ends
yeah uh will we turn around sorry
dragoon versus john burke the game of
the day in group b wow uh i don't know
how we got here
but this looks john barkey's
worse
is he i get it he's not a pawn but
definitely worse he's definitely worse
the question is
probably not enough yeah i don't think
it's enough i mean this rook is such a
monster no i actually think he's just
completely completely fine right yeah
yeah yeah
i mean you just stay with the king on
the thing is
you're not gonna reach
e5 and even if you do i'm going to give
you a check
yeah it doesn't actually take you away
and then i'm gonna go back
and you have to keep the rook this rook
is completely stuck to the defense of
the a pawn you cannot sacrifice this a
pawn in any good way
so this is just a draw this is
completely dry i don't see it how do we
get here
that's a good question i think we left
it off somewhere around
this we left it off
yeah and i think john burke decided that
he was not really playing for a win
let's just establish a bishop on d2
and uh
yeah yeah
and and this is a very nice this is
actually a very nice technical uh
decision when he white text is the king
on d2 he plays this really nice sequence
of rook b king c3
i think a lot of people here would be
like defending the pawn or going rook b3
rook g3 and he said nope the correct way
to draw this is to put the pattern a5
the rook on before it's like wait and
wait yeah he doesn't even take on f4
just wait he just went you don't want to
take on f4 because king b5 would
actually probably win it it might
actually even just directly win i don't
even guarantee that but why why think
about this this is good to the defense
of the a pawn keep the king stuck
and the c5 and this is as dangerous as
it gets because he has uh allowed the
king to d5 he's kind of in a zug zone
uh if he moves the rook from the fourth
round because i can go here right ah now
you want to go g4 is that no but g4
drops the f4 phone
no uh here i wanted to go
but okay okay it doesn't matter that's
fine i can't use g6 but this is what i
was saying king g65 rookie four is still
fine exactly so yeah this is just gonna
be a draw
i don't think anyway
i don't see any way for camille to make
any progress have we missed any game i
don't think we have i
don't think so i think we went through
most of it should we go back to the a
group absolutely all right especially
the dura game
back to the a group the game oh my
goodness the game of the day between
misra and gledura in
group a
[Music]
lot clarified a little bit he didn't he
never played d4 he
yeah i mean we said d4 was just an
automatic move right for the last like
10 minutes yeah
all the way to move 20 no never mind not
move 22 i think we were all the way to
move here queen to d7 yeah even before
queen d7 we thought d4 he was going to
be playing b3 b5 a completely different
approach let me see any of this coming
queen to c2
black is not playing d4 white is not
playing d4 rook 36 we trade off
and now we got this position
we kind of wonder why black gave up upon
look
black still has
compensation yeah i agree with you
whether it's enough for equality i'm not
convinced i'm not convinced either i
like i like white it is a pond i'm
starting to like white queen a lot of g2
kind of stuck but so
with the king on h8
i would think that perhaps black has
more
compensation than with the king on g8
why i'm saying that is that after you
take take i have this extra option of
just simply exchanging the queens and if
we get to this position
my pawns are on the right collar
yeah
your bishop can never attack them your
knight i don't see a good way to get
back into the game if you go knight to
h6 boom knight e3 you don't want to do
that i'm gonna take all your squares
away
there's no good way at least to my eyes
to get the knight into play and if you
cannot get the knight into play well
unfortunately you don't have any targets
no i i i agree with you christian i
think that
there is comp but not enough not
not enough and i don't think that he
should go for the end game you could go
for something like this right but even
this maybe i can consider even taking
yeah
black is on like take it don't play on
the light squares you're on the verge of
losing this end game right yeah i mean i
understand you still have this
tremendous pawn on e3
you're going to reinforce it with the
bishop on d4 but
i mean you're down upon if i do manage
to let's say play king to g tonight to g
one queen to f3 then knight two ninety
two yeah
it's a game for two results yeah
absolutely exactly
too much light square control here for
white i mean there there's
total control by black on the dark
squares precisely but white is going to
ignore it he's going to play around
those squares
and he's going to try to consolidate and
prove this his king signed majority
i i like misha's chances actually but
it's still a game what is the time
situation wait does he actually have 10
seconds he does
10 seconds more moves d4 plays so he
does commit
yeah he's going for this 93 idea i mean
i think he's more or less forced to be
honest and one minute by the way for
mishra two moves to go let's uh stick
with this one at least until they make
the time control
um
all right what are we expecting here
queen da2 is actually pretty logical
queen d2 makes a lot of sense yeah i'm
not sure i want to allow a4 though
probably not right
well if you don't want to allow it you
can go queen to a2
queenie quinn a2 is but queen a2 maybe
knight e3 and then you want to take on
a5 what a greedy guy actually i cannot
you cannot take that
cheats
that's too greedy
let's see where he goes
queen grenade
all right queen 282
i still think you have to play knight e3
asks an immediate question how do you
defend the pawn on a5 do you want to go
passive or do you continue with knight
to e3 playing passive here is very sad
he played king h7 what a guy
that's not passive the opposite of
passive
no so the idea is clear if you do take i
go queen to e2 and i have a feeling you
might have some problems i feel like
white's just getting made it
exactly
so king to h7 what a what a decision um
i like practical decisions yeah
at some point here what needs to really
consider if he wants to go king f1 queen
e2 right
i like king f1 actually
king f1
and what if i do something like
queen wait and they are queenie two
now you're trying to give me a check i
am definitely trying to give you a check
he's actually played something else
entirely he's played the move
replay
queen back to situ well
i will guarantee you something christian
we're not we're not guessing
we're not gonna see king
you don't think so
i mean it's funny because it's like an
offer of a three-fold repetition but
king jane is such a dumb move in this
position
yeah is that a three-fold repetition i
mean it would be an invitation but
obviously not
we just uh
i think we just we just pushed the
partner too long here knight h6
i like this actually
hinting uh that he's uh refocusing his
attention
towards the pawn on g3 i think michelle
just did like a very uh a very 13 year
old thing what did he do i think he
asked his opponent if he's not move
forward
allowed to add that to your opponent by
the way um
yeah yeah i mean he's going to get all
this for his experience
experience uh ultimately and he has so
much experience for his age yeah yeah
yeah it's crazy how many tournaments
he's played it's also funny like
there's this kind of 13 year old that
they don't feel that they're 13 because
i i can count how many times i've seen
misha around the world not just around
the us like around the world yeah
i just saw him like sochi oh yeah he's
everywhere everywhere no i mean he's
been traveling for a very long time
um actually in 2020 when nobody was
playing chess he was playing tournament
after tournament somewhere in europe
yeah he played a lot of these norm
tournaments in saturday's first
saturdays and stuff like that mainly in
hungary but also some events here and
there trying to get his norms and
experience as well and he did he was
gunning for that record yeah and he got
it he got it yeah and i think there was
a lot of debate about it when it did
happen but i think uh
we can we can stop that debate yeah we
can put that to rest
he's obviously as gm we just don't know
exactly what his trunk is right now
because it might be 26 plus
it could be it could very well be i mean
he is holding his own yeah quite handily
against these 26 plus level players and
once again to score six and a half out
of seven again
an average rating of 25 30. that puts
him at around 26 50 2700 close to that
probably even higher actually when i
think about it yeah i mean he's going to
have to so objectively how are we doing
actually this move knight h6 is a lot
more annoying
than i was giving it first thoughts
because okay knight f5 and queen g6 are
pretty annoying moves sure i don't
really want to play knight g5
but uh as somebody in the chat pointed
out uh shout out to patrick who's been
with us every day
queen e6 queen h3 is actually not such a
patrick daily yeah not such a
dumb idea here
i mean queen is exponential
in the game so you need to be a little
careful
wait what
queen e6 queen h3 yeah what if i defend
with queen f2 at that point
yeah but knight g for queen ew but then
i go net f5
oh you want to go knight f5 yeah you run
out of defenders of g3
makes sense yeah
huh
so as we said earlier i think that white
still has compensation actually this
move queen c2 made no sense to me uh i
understand it was his 40th move but
perhaps that's why he made it made it
but i mean queensland cannot possibly be
a good move right
no he kind of uh gave a tempo away at
least yeah probably even two
because king h7 was very useful
somehow i feel black is went from having
compassion to being fine yeah
it does feel like ledora is uh
finding his way out yeah of the mess
that he put himself in
and the problem is
this knight on g2 doesn't really have a
great prospect
in the position
they're kind of stepping on each other's
who's these two nights if you go knight
to e1i to f3 you would love together
right but unfortunately there's another
night there the hoofs the hoops yeah
no i agree uh
it's still a lot of work here to be done
for how how are they uh calling them in
in russia the superfluous nights
spartaflow's knights yeah you know them
there's been a concept
yeah popularized by doradski and
it really is a true concept yeah you
only have one good knight that can go to
a good square yup currently that square
is f3
all right and and i think we have to go
back to the b group yeah i think so
because in the other game let's we
actually see the theodore is playing
and it's very clear what's happened uh
white has won a pawn
and it it almost feels like the game
starts again
this is going to be a hugely long game
where the bishop is definitely superior
in the knight but the knight is actually
in a very nice place on d4
big question right now do you take on f3
or you don't
no i don't think you hold that
we actually get into a very similar
endgame to what you uh yeah mentioned
you do but in this particular one i
already got my rook to b7 and you don't
get your rook to the file in time
unless i'm missing something
maybe you do
let's go here
oh sorry not there yeah and then uh i go
g4
yeah and how is this position
i would think that let's just see if i
go here no knight
yeah the structure needs to stay like
that structure has stayed
all right let's let's make a normal move
and how do i make progress how do you
build up
yeah this might take a while
i have a feeling this is lost though
for uh for black
right right right right no i mean you
always get that that feeling the problem
is how do you prove it right
you look on knight to d4 you have some
ideas of knight to e6 i can always try
to defend with king to g5 i'm always
going to harass you now that actually we
don't have the h pawns i think this
helps black
it usually helps the defender right
right
uh the closer we get to simplifying the
position to no pawns on the board with
the easiest draw the easier
because right now
i have a feeling that i can go king to
f6 you could try to move away with the
knight and king to g5 and not have to
worry about giving up two points
in order to exchange one
um
yeah this one is going to be a long game
and
by the way this is the moment right now
yeah he and look at him we can see you
young he he's trying to remember
those days in uh a chinese chess camp uh
12 years 14 16 years ago when he
probably looked at this uh position with
dingley ran back when they were both
2300s
and he doesn't remember anything
he's just trying to understand and
um
give his best judgment of the ensuing
position
which it's hard to say it's an
interesting practical decision right is
is that table based or we're not in
table based one two three one two three
unknown not in table base not yet table
base but the evolution is pretty low we
we turned on the engine to see if it had
a table based on validation or not right
but the eval of 1.7 seems pretty low
okay i don't think it should be winning
at a 1.7
but that being said i don't i don't know
if black is lost yeah and there's no
other way right no i mean i have to take
the the bishop for white yeah yeah you
have to take the bishop there's no
there's no tricks
no no tricks i mean you can give a check
first but that's not going to change
much
yeah we get into the same position yeah
yeah big moment big moment here very
very big moment for us and i actually
don't know if just moving the bishop
it leads to ca that was like c8 or
something right like how do we evaluate
this end game
i'm always worried about leaving the
bishop on the board actually in this
type of situations right it's a very
active bishop but surprisingly there's
no targets there's no targets and it's
surprisingly controlled yeah
so
i feel it's more of a liability somehow
you feel bishop after
the crack right
yes i would probably
play bishop takes f3 yeah this is a
tough one this is a real difference
between like high 2700s and others
they'll be able to make this call
without too much hesitation but also
psychologically
uh the humans want to simplify the
position yeah i agree with you and
you're starting to look at bishop takes
f3 and you want to make it work
now we don't know whether it works or
not and i can guarantee you he doesn't
know whether it works or not either
right but i have a feeling that
psychologically he will go for the
decision that simplifies the position
more
let's wait and see i might be proven
wrong um
you uh
oh yeah yeah we do have a result yeah
yeah and check out made it checker
got made it we left it off
we left it in a position that we thought
should be lost but where's the end yes
yes queen to h oh we did play he did
play knight e6 and he did go queen e4
queen three four one analyzed this here
there was this interesting with queen a4
very very nice geometry
uh
knight ef5 and then this cool move rook
g2
because you you're just lost here
there's no china yeah
you don't have time oh yeah and check
nice nice
nice queen to d5
to g1 and actually that was just that's
it final move this is it yeah uh
well another devastating
uh finish just like the one we saw in
the game of jacobian versus beer
beautiful finish and we will get jj
actually on the show
what else do we have let's see
jacobson versus
antipath they went straight into those
type of positions
somehow this one feels much closer to a
white wind than uh than the game between
uh
yu yang yi and tioda yeah this one in
particular looks pretty bad because if i
ever set up some kind of bind attacking
your pawn on the f7 square and i get my
pawn to g5 that's it because you know
yeah then you can take on f7
a king's
kings and pawn and game and just going
to be winning yeah yeah
and that one is easy i have a feeling
that it's hard to avoid that unless you
go rook h2 like the second
rook to h2 i think you want white to
establish
the pawn on h4 of course yeah yeah yeah
yeah you do want that and if you go
chief and if you go g4 i'll take take f5
right so like right that that's that's a
good point you don't have g5 because it
worked to g2 yeah
um and if you change the last pawn then
we know that that's a
draw somewhere i have a feeling that's
important i don't know if it's a draw
but it'll make
white's
task a lot harder so king to
rook to h
two now
we have uh two potentially very long
end games developing in round number
five one in group a one in group b
the game
between um
the other and new yongi as well as this
game between
brandon jacobson who is trying to find a
way to break
misha antipov
and actually
in the meantime we did get
an interview we have uh the second
winner of today's round
ali marandi ali welcome back yeah thank
you welcome back to the studio tell us a
little bit about this game you're
playing uh up here in the collegiate
sphere now of course you just graduated
you're moving on to a phd program but
you do know nico check out quite well
what can you tell us about this game how
did you approach it
yes so uh
okay i wasn't sure about what to play
before the tournament but i picked like
king's indian just for this game and i
thought it would be a pleasant surprise
and um
yeah so i did expect this system what he
always pretty much plays
and uh
until like last night i was going to
play knight g4 instead of b6 which is
like the main main line
and it's like a big theory
and uh this morning i basically was like
okay i have to play something a little
bit more
like
the offbeat different and i know my
teammate nico played b6 like twice
and he's a kings indian expert so i'm
like okay if he plays it then he
probably knows something
and uh definitely one did you get to
discuss uh with nicole no i think that
he has
no he has his own problems to deal with
for sure and yeah i played this line and
i was like
sure that we'll get a close position and
okay i didn't know exactly like how
white would proceed because there are
not that many games and i just relied on
like so what's the point of b6 give us
the rundown i guess
the idea of b6 is like sometimes black
wants to go ed4 before d5 happens
and then you eventually put the bishop
on b7 and attack e4
and it kind of provokes d5 so you want
to get a like usual king's indian
position
with the b6 included which is generally
useful because it prevents like
immediate c5s so it's not like a total
useless move especially with the bishop
white is always ready to play with c5 so
yeah b6 kind of prevents immediate c5s
and um yeah knight d2 i think 98 is
normal yeah and maybe i can just go f5
but i as far as i remembered c5 was the
move
so yeah i played that and then he played
very quickly which
i was a bit surprised because
i was sure that it's a new position for
him but he was still playing very
quickly so
and since i don't always play the king's
indian i was sometimes doubting myself
but i liked my position very quickly on
like after especially he takes f5 i was
very happy with the position he played
it like without thinking much and to be
honest i think like like black's
probably better here no after d takes e6
actually as you were mentioning the next
four moves he only spent
um four minutes that's a lot that's not
a lot huge decision for the position
yeah yeah and i think ef5 is not a good
move because after what i got in the
game put the bishop on e6 queen on f7
i mean okay he has these nice squares d5
and c6 but the knight on b3 is so
outside the game that uh i think it's
just easier to play with the black
pieces no absolutely and as you
mentioned
uh the knight would love to be on the
other side the knight would be
yeah very happy on g5 unfortunately you
cannot get there right but he doesn't
have enough time because he's very often
losing something you have to to meet the
bishop takes d5 so knight d2
yeah bishop to c1 knight to f6 uh
keeping the tension alive knight to e4
now i bet you were happy with them
beautiful night yeah yeah yeah i mean
like especially when that knight was on
e8 and now it's on e4 and like two moves
and i'm threatening knight c3 as to deal
with that yeah my rooks are coming and
like it's just easy to play with the
with the black pieces and at this point
you just look at the position and you
feel like you don't know the exact
assessment because you don't have an
engine but you feel like all of your
pieces are just beautifully placed you
don't have any bad piece in the position
you feel like you're all right at least
all right for sure yeah i was always
like checking fes and like something on
e4 or something but like it never
happens like so i had no problems at all
and
i didn't know exactly how to break
through but i didn't have to know
because he would spend a lot of time
checking always he takes f4
and potential things hanging in the air
c4 is hanging so he has to be the one
watching out for all the tactics and
eventually he actually cracked because
like i don't even have to release the
tension so i tried
yeah i made some waiting moves here i
knew i had something but i couldn't find
exactly what so i just played king h8
how bad can it be of course just put the
rook on
yeah why not
i was certain that some blunder was
going to happen at some point from him
right and right now he was
still move 26 only 20 minutes left on
the clock and he was burning two three
minutes every single moment exactly
um i'm just slowly improving like i want
to take on f4 at some point so the rook
on e7 gets to g7 like just very calm
moves and uh
yeah once you have to play moves such as
king to h1 at move 25 and then back to
g1 at move 28 it's a symptom of a bad
position already like white cannot do
anything he just has to hope for me
making a mistake but i would not take
any extreme measures until he blundered
then absolutely and which one loses
knight to d4 yeah yeah no i mean he just
hung the c4 c4 actually quite nice line
if he played rookie one instead of
knight d4
on move
34 i believe
yeah here i can go queen g2 even just
simplify the position and the knight f2
at the end
i mean it's just a f file yeah queen
takes f2 and this is just the winning
end yeah this is what i saw and i was i
was sure that excuse me it's good enough
and um
just to go back to the
position in the game knight to g5 and
yeah at the end i had to be a bit
technical but
i don't think i ever messed it up this
is exactly what we said we said that
okay you're an exchange up you have some
technical issues but if you find the
right moves you can solve that yeah
knight e6 and queen a4 i think is very
good because now i make sure my queen
comes to d4
i mean
and then i put it on e5 and there is no
way any problems on this long diagonal
lens came over absolutely yeah simple
principles yeah at the end was also
quite nice i think and centralize your
pieces
and that was a very nice
touch at the end
jj congratulations who do you have
tomorrow
i think i have dragoon
big game tomorrow we're going to let you
uh get some rest get some preparation in
and we'll see you tomorrow sounds good
hopefully here excellent
all right what a game what a game and
let's look at the results so far
in both groups we have
round five results in group a we have
two results aram hacobian just a
devastating win against jonas beer
a peaceful draw between sam savion and
grigory oparin and still two games
pending
the fight between nicolas theodore new
yongi and abhimanyu mishra versus
benjamin gleduran how about the b group
well in the b group we still have a few
games spending uh
actually quite a lot of games spending
that's because we have five games
instead of four
that helps that definitely helps
christian so that adds another one we
have three game spending guillermo
vasquez versus tigran
tunian zuzan chow versus christopher you
and camille dragoon versus john burke
nikolas czecho fell under the sharp
sword of jj alimorani as we just saw and
brandon jacobson drew his game against
misha and people really well yeah that
was actually a lot more dead drawn than
we thought it was um
interesting interesting well alejandro
as we are getting ready to uh wrap it up
uh your final thoughts about round
number five i think it was really cool i
think we uh we had so many
things i didn't expect theodore putting
pressure on yu yang yi for example i
think was unexpected i think the fact
that misha is putting pressure on ladura
from a bad position is unexpected
uh and
a lot of moved games i think even the
game between dragoon and burke was like
super fun very interesting things all
around so many
different positions i love this game i
love this tournament because you don't
get everything that you expect it's like
a little more wide open yep and i think
today was a very good example of that oh
absolutely the two decisive results that
we had were just marvelous games uh and
we will be coming back tomorrow with
round number six join us at 3 30 p.m
central time and you can start watching
the games at 1pm central time see you
tomorrow two minutes then join us
tomorrow
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the saint
louis chess club is prohibited
you